the king of monsters has taken many
forms over the last 60 years let's not
mention the 1998 Matthew Broderick
outing but now it looks like the lizard
has found his Hollywood home at
legendary pictures and he's bringing
some of his friends along for the ride
I'm Simon and this is your kaiju
fighting news updates when Godzilla was
released in 2014 it was simply a
standalone reboot of the classic
Japanese monster movie two years later
the Gareth it was directed movie is now
the first part of an ongoing cinematic
monster universe with the next part Kong
Skull Island jus in 2017 the
much-anticipated showdown godzilla vs.
Kong has now been given an official
release date by distributor Warner
while Godzilla 2 has shifted its own
release slot as reported by Variety
Godzilla vs. Kong will stomp into
cinemas on May 29th 2020 Godzilla 2
moves back to March 22nd 2019 from its
original release slot of June 8th 2018
the move is further evidence that
following the success of Deadpool and
Batman V Superman dawn of Justice
studios are increasingly less concerned
with releasing their tempo movies in the
summer months Kong Scott Island recently
wrapped production and a behind the
scenes video provided a first look at
the upcoming King Kong prequel the film
focuses upon a group of explorers who
embark for adventures on a mysterious
tropical isle and encounter an island
filled with strange creatures including
a certain giant ape are you excited for
some king sized kaiju combat what giant
monsters would you like to see join the
action let me know in the comments or
come find me on Twitter I'm at the jaqen
all thanks for watching and for your
entertainment news keep it GameSpot's